[Musique]
47 degrés dehors 16 à l'intérieur
ça fait quatre jours que je joue 12
heures je suis à las vegas en table
finale du tournoi de poker que je suis
venu disputer ce sont les championnats
du monde
le directeur de tournoi annonce les
finalistes
les les supporters français crient dans
les gradins
grosse grosse pression on monte sur le
ring
nous étions plus de 1000 au départ et
maintenant plus que trois lorsqu'une
joueuses miss tous ses jetons contre moi
cela sous-entend des cartes très forte
de son côté à un moment où les miennes
sont complètement nul donc je vais pas
compter dessus moi ce que je veux savoir
à ce moment là c'est si cette joueuse
elle me ment par rapport à la force de
ses cartes parce que si oui je vais la
prendre la main dans le sac et
l'éliminer et sinon c'est moi qui serait
éliminé en troisième position donc c'est
elle ou moi
alors la raison ici me dit d'abandonner
la peur aussi
c'est rare de bluffer c'est super dur en
plus donc ou alors est-ce qu'elle en est
capable parce qu'elle est arrivé jusque
là
alors la panique à bord
je sais plus quoi faire mais il faut que
je me ressaisis j'ai pas le choix donc
je la regarde plutôt elle tient comment
elle réagit alors health ayem est la
sortie elle a enclenché son mode
pokerface c'est à dire qu'elle ne bouge
plus du tout
pour masquer ses émotions et alors elle
va rester comme ça dix minutes parce que
ces temps que moi je vais mettre à me
décider
alors à la fin elle bouge elle pose sa
main sur sa boisson comme ça à côté
d'elle
et ça ça tire une sonnette d'alarmé
parce qu'en fait cette décontraction
dans un moment en jeu comme ça en pleine
négociation c'est un peu suspect ça
rappelle les joueurs de poker quand ils
caressent leurs mains voire même leur
carte pour se donner du réconfort
alors elle a vu que j'avais vues et ses
yeux s'écarquillent un peu plus
alors je me lance je décide que elle a
le droit d'avoir soif oui mais pas
maintenant parce que déjà on n'est pas
dans un barbecue là et en plus il fait
super froid
et je les lis minel bleus fait
alors quelques heures après
cette secousse contre cette jeune femme
je gagne le tournoi et garder la tête
froide ça m'a vraiment permis de prendre
une décision difficile à ce moment là et
je deviens alors la première française à
être champion du monde de poker et je
suis toujours là seul pour le moment
merci je me présente je suis ravi d'être
avec vous ce soir bonjour je m'appelle
vanessa hellebuyck j'ai toujours aimé
jouer j'ai toujours adoré ça j'étais une
joueuse de piano avant de transformer en
joueuse de tournois et aujourd'hui j'ai
plaisir à transmettre mon expérience
dans les alpes dans les entreprises pour
apporter du lien je veux montrer les
bénéfices au delà du poker a travaillé
son empathie ses émotions évidemment les
prises de décision les enjeux le stress
ça peut faire partie de notre quotidien
alors vous vous dites oui d'accord mais
est-ce que plutôt ça ça ferait pas du
mentalisme
banon pardon c'est juste qu'en fait en
général on est bien meilleur en repérage
quand camouflage c'est une question de
survie dans la vie en tant qu'être
humain on a quand même plus souvent
intérêt à voir et se comprendre qu à se
rouler en boule
mais en fait se rouler en boule ça peut
avoir quelques avantages et surtout dans
cette anecdote il y a trois éléments que
je considère moi comme des atouts au
quotidien et c'est ça que j'aimerais
partager avec vous ce soir
donc non voilà est alors le premier ça
serait de pouvoir sortir à un bouclier
parfois pour rester maîtres de nos
émotions pour mieux se protéger les uns
les autres on a tous des jardins secrets
on aimerait bien ne pas les transformer
en gros boulevard on veut choisir ce
qu'on dévoile et on va très rapidement
se jauger les uns les autres en quelques
minutes donc ça serait vraiment dommage
de rater nos entretiens nos entrevues
parce que on s'est dandinée toulon on à
renier notre bague où on notre voix
s'est soudainement mise à muer alors
comment on peut faire parce que c'est
pas évident de cacher ses émotions
on essaie souvent de se rassurer en
réfléchissant 11 il faut que je me calme
et puis dix minutes après il faut
vraiment que je me calme et puis on se
calme pas en fait et en fin de compte
stoppez la réaction en premier c'est
plus facile qu'on ne le croit comme ça
hop sans réfléchir up sur commande et
pour ça j'ai une petite recettes
apprises par nécessité c'est vrai la
poker face alors si à dégainer quand les
émotions fortes nous mentonnais parce
qu'on sait qu'elles vont futé
pour ça c'est pas très compliqué il
suffit de fixer un point et puis glissé
légèrement les yeux jusqu'à ce que la
vue se brouille il faut pas dévier le
regarde tout de suite parce que ça ça va
nous déconcentrer c'est plutôt niveau 2
mais déjà là on arrive tout de suite
dans une bulle de confort on faire une
sorte de cocon on arrive même à sentir
bien dedans et on fait le vide avec le
monde extérieur
et c'est nous qui décidons quand on est
prêt à revenir
alors maintenant je vais vous demander
quelque chose je vais vous laisser trois
secondes parce que je suis vraiment une
fille sympa pour me faire votre plus
belle pokerface imaginer je viens de
tomber là comme ça devant vos yeux
ébahis j'en suis capable alors
j'aimerais voir chez vous ni votre
surprise ni votre joie ça serait sympa
alors 3 2 1 à vous montrer moins votre
pokerface
waouh
vous êtes entraînés avant
franchement je suis impressionné merci
beaucoup
alors là poker fait c'est déjà bien
franchement le bouclier on est déjà bien
parti mais parfois ça suffit pas parce
que balla on bouge plus du tout et on
aimerait bien se donner un peu plus de
courage parfois pour pour oser plus pour
aller plus loin et alors là pourquoi pas
sortir notre cap du placard pour
justement osé pour se donner ce courage
et parce que finalement on nous dit très
souvent un soyez confiants ne stressez
pas restez vous mêmes oui alors parfois
mois déjà ça peut être dangereux et puis
en plus des fois on a envie de rester
dans son trou plutôt et d'envoyer
quelqu'un d'autre quelqu'un de plus
courageux quelqu'un qui va pas perdre
ses moyens au pire moment par exemple
parce que la peur tu l'esprit et ça se
voit mais la confiance aussi c'est super
transparent un grand grand champion de
poker m'avait prédit quelques mois avant
que j'allais gagner ce tournoi on était
plus de 1000 participants
donc bon outre le fait que lui ça soit
un jedi moi je suis arrivé en
conquérante la confiance totalement
booth c'est ça finit par dégouliner sur
les autres participants en fait j'avais
pas peur et ça a fini par leur faire
peur j'ai même pas fait exprès en fait
et puis et puis c'est finalement ça a
imposé une forme de respect au minimum
et même ma mère en fait elle me
reconnaît pas sur les photos elle mais
c'est ma vie ça alors que dans la vie
c'est un gif animés fin qu'est ce qui
s'est passé quoi
alors en enfilant ce costume de courage
c'est ça qui va finalement me transforme
et c'est ça qui va faire que je vais
oser agir différemment que je vais
libérer un autre potentiel
en fait ça va changer ma voix ça va
changer ma posture mon état d'esprit
et bien sûr c'est toujours moi mais
c'est moi améliorer seymour a transformé
c'est moi qui joue mon meilleur jeu
alors
maintenant
j'aimerais bien voir demander quelque
chose comment vous êtes vous quand vous
savez que vous allez gagner je vous dis
moi j'aimerais bien vous réussissez tous
vos prochains objectifs sincèrement
alors montré moins votre posture quand
vous savez déjà que vous allez gagner
non non vous n'êtes pas comme ça non non
montrez moi ce que c'est une posture de
quand on le sait on en est convaincu
voilà maintenant vous rester comme ça
jusqu'à la fin
et alors
c'est une fois finalement c'est le
costume enfilé en fait plus je vais
avoir raison dans certaines situations
plus je vais la sortir ma cape par
exemple pour le coup de poker que je
vous raconte l'anecdote évidemment pour
moi le risque était énorme mais la
chandelle était aussi donc voilà ça va
me rassurer pour la reporter à nouveau
et puis alors là c'est bien parce qu'on
a déjà une panoplie pour nous finalement
commence à ressembler à quelque chose
parce que on a notre bouclier on a notre
cap
mais le truc c'est qu'on n'est pas tout
seul il ya aussi les autres et c'est
vrai que des fois on aimerait bien un
petit coup de pouce on aimerait bien
pourquoi pas une loupe pour mieux
distinguer ce qui se passe autour mieux
déceler le vrai du faux mieux comprendre
mieux interpréter
il y à vraiment des véritables trésors
dans les décors dans les détails qui
racontent des sentiments et des
histoires et ça serait vraiment dommage
de les rater il ya même des
micro-expressions de moins d'une seconde
quand les émotions sont intenses
alors je vais d'abord commencer par vous
raconter une petite histoire où j'ai pas
du tout sorti ma loupe ni même mes yeux
à ce niveau là j'avais rendez vous avec
une cliente potentielle que je ne
connaissais pas et il y avait beaucoup
de monde autour d'elle donc je suis
arrivé je vais aborder de dos a commencé
très très bien j'ai fait bonjour esther
et elle s'est retournée
m'enfin ça ne se fait pas mais vous n'y
êtes pas c'est pas possible à alors là
je peux vous dire j'ai pas enclenché
mapouka fais je me disais qu el kish
elle s'appelle pas ester je me suis
gouré de prénom mais en fait non c'est
juste qu'en fait elle voulait pas ce
degré de familiarité entre nous vous
imaginez si je l'avais tutoyer et
finalement si j'avais regardé un peu
mieux au tour le décor le champagne
coulait à flot les gens lui faire
pratiquement le baisemain bon
j'aurais sûrement tenter une autre
approche alors je suis parti avec
beaucoup de classe à dieu et sert
à dieu contrat
et avant cela c'était une info de
premier plan on se dit mais comment elle
a vu être aussi peu éveillées et je les
ratés quoi et alors ce qui est
intéressant souvent quand même
normalement plus dur à percevoir ces les
infos de second plan
là par exemple imaginez vous êtes en
réunion où vous êtes à une table en
train de jouer comme ça avec un joueur
de poker qui lui ça y est il a enclenché
sa pokerface ou votre patron il y en a
qui savent très bien le faire essayer il
enclenché son mode pause café
oui sauf que juste derrière il ya sa
femme par exemple qui a vu ses cartes
et qui elle est en mode ou jeu sous une
paire d'as a alors ça c'est pratique
quand même comme un faut obtenir c'est
exactement la même chose que si votre
patron il arrive il vous annonce une
super nouvelle et puis derrière il ya
son assistant qui a l'air complètement
dévastée ouais c'est intéressant quand
même et alors il ya même des trésors en
visio parce que moi on m'a dit récemment
le langage corporel à distance ça compte
plus on s'en fout
alors tous les jours moi je vois des
trucs du genre le projet se passe bien
où l'équipe n'a vraiment pas pris de
retard
en gros gros plan
c'est cool
alors là c'est pas évident parce que
effectivement
une fois qu'on a vu finalement on se
rend compte que ça fait pas tout ça fait
pas comprendre en fait et pour
l'histoire donc je vous racontais de la
fille avec sa boisson en fait on a une
petite voix qui ne peut nous alerter
instinctivement qu'il nous dit t'as vu
c'est bizarre
et là on creuse un peu comme une fausse
note parce que on veut surtout pas tirer
de conclusions hâtives du genre à elle
s'est gratté l'oeil allemand j'ai
compris bon ça c'est dangereux
évidemment nous ce qu'on veut c'est en
fait c'est c'est bien interprété et
c'est souvent le contexte qui va nous
aider pour ça qui va nous éclairer qui
va changer la donne
alors en fait si vous regardez là
maintenant d'un petit peu plus près je
suis en train de trembler très doucement
mais je tremble à votre avis qu'est ce
que j'ai est-ce que je tremble de peur
est-ce que je tremble de froid
je vais rester comme ça si vous n'êtes
pas
alors un joueur qui fait ça soudainement
c'est l'excitation
c'est une paire d'as et la joie vous
imaginez si on comprend linverse un
manager un recruteur
il y a des signes avant-coureurs de
fatigue de colère
dans la gestuelle dans les silences on
peut voir ça avant que ça ne se passe
des signes avant-coureurs de burnout si
par exemple
et
il est plus facile comme ça de créer du
lien vraiment sur des relations
authentiques et maintenir un lien fort
il est possible de le faire comme ça de
faire bien attention les uns les autres
on peut tous être plus réactifs pour ça
pour devancer et s'entraider on peut
tous me réussir collectivement et
individuellement
et pour surtout maintenir ce lien entre
nous faire plus attention les uns aux
autres c'est ce que je m'applique à
transmettre en entreprise alors vous
pouvez éventuellement de temps en temps
ressortir ces objets quand vous en avez
besoin évidemment au cas où et laisser
un peu plus le corps faire le travail
donc son bouclier pokerface pour se
protéger très très rapidement
s'habiller de courage avec sa cape la
sortir plus souvent du placard et puis
affiné sa lecture essayer de mieux
interpréter avec cette loupe et
évidemment leur ces objets ils vont nous
servir sur le moment bien sûr mais pas
que parce qu'en fait c'est avec le temps
que
finalement ça va développer une nouvelle
routine en fait c'est une véritable
transformation assignés à ce moment là
c'est vous en 2.0
alors vous avez appris de nouvelles
langues parfois de nouveaux codes
informatiques
vous pouvez jouer la carte plus souvent
du langage émotionnel
donc je vais vous demander encore un
petit quelque chose est ce que vous
pouvez me faire un petit air triste
maintenant
c'est dur hein
parce que je vais devoir vous laisser
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]